tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel
blackout autour du témoignage du juge
noël bex à lyon le dispositif policier
reste en place
liban après la reprise des combats à
beyrouth colère et découragement dans la
population
tournée en europe pour anouar el-sadate
après sa visite aux états unis il sera
dimanche à paris tabarly à tf1 en
refusant de signer une pétition contre
moi mes concurrents ont fait preuve de
fair play
bonsoir vous savez déjà sans doute que
le juge noël d'aix a été retrouvée 54
heures après son enlèvement à 15 km de
lyon il avait été enlevé lundi soir près
de son domicile à et il a été retrouvée
ligotée à un arbre dans un petit bois à
ternay toujours dans le département du
rhône à 11 heures du soir
hier la police était prévenue par
téléphone une voix anonyme sans doute
une voix de femme indiqué à quel endroit
se trouvait le juge inutile de dire le
soulagement qu'a apporté alors cette
nouvelle
le juge est vivant il a certes subi une
rude épreuve il a été malmené il est
commotionné on le serait à moins
le garde des sceaux alain peyrefitte lui
adressé un télégramme pour lui dire
l'émotion de l'ensemble de la
magistrature française également sa
solidarité pour lui souhaiter aussi de
retrouver au plus tôt sa place parmi ses
collègues soulagement oui mais la sphère
ne saurait s'arrêter là on a enlevé un
juge
on ne sait toujours pas pourquoi on
cherche vainement sur quoi pourrait
porter ce nouveau chantage à la vie
humaine et c'est encore alain peyrefitte
qui a rappelé tout sera mis en oeuvre
pour retrouver les coupables
jean-pierre à bout notre envoyé spécial
à lyon nous fait revivre cette journée
et nous donne les derniers éléments de
l'enquète c'est ici dans ce petit bois
de ternes et que le juge noël d'aix est
restée attachée à un arbre pendant 18
heures
lorsque les gendarmes ont découvert la
nuit dernière à la suite d'un appel des
ravisseurs
noël d'aix était épuisée transis de
froid les mains entravées blessés par
des menottes un bâillon l'empêcher de
crier
pourtant le juge des tec à 500 mètres
des premières habitations du village
mais personne n'avait rien vu pour
qu'ils puissent se réchauffer recevoir
les premiers soins
les gendarmes l'ont conduit dans une
villa proche du petit bois chez madame
bonnart et son fils le juge leur a parlé
de son enlèvement
il a été un peu bousculé mais pas
vraiment mal traités et l'emmena c'est
un peu bien sûr avec un revolver et la
retire agit là ils l'ont fait tourner un
peu je crois pour le perdre d'un côté de
l'autre ils ont changé de voiture
dire qu'il est presque toujours restée
en voiture non à ni'lin gmail était
injoignable implose il avait une cagoule
et puis il avait perdu la notion du
temps est ce qu'il a pu identifier ses
ravisseurs et ce qu'il sait pourquoi il
a été enlevé
il sait pas
malgré sa fatigue le juge a pu dire aux
policiers que ses ravisseurs étaient
jeunes il parlait un français sans
accent c'était peut-être des lyonnais
ils connaissaient bien le juge qu'il te
plaît par son prénom
les ravisseurs voulaient obtenir la
libération d'un détenu dont ils n'ont
pas indiqué le nom pour le préfet de
police il s'agit de rapts manqués les
malfaiteurs cherchait manifestement un
échange et cet échange ne s'est pas fait
et ils n'ont même pas pris du reste là
le risque de le demander j'observe que
aucun contact a été pris avec nous que
aucune proposition était fait de même
par voix anonymes de lettres ou de prêt
ou par parallèle le carré une salle de
rédaction
je constate aussi que on l'a tout de
même libéré et qu'on l'a libéré sain et
sauf dans une des affaires de cette
espèce de choses l'une où on libère
contre quelque chose où l'on tue or là
on n'a rien eu et on n'a pas tué on n'a
pas tué parce que on a lu avoir un
moment donné un sentiment de très grands
risques
oui le très grand risque et c'est en
cela que je crois que l'affairé manque
que les enquêteurs une idée de la
personnalité de ses ravisseurs
je crois que
nous devrions situer ses ravisseurs dans
là parce que j'appellerais cela la
petite pègre lyonnaise le juge noël
d'aix a indiqué aux enquêteurs que ses
ravisseurs n'appartenait certainement
pas au gang des lyonnais
la seconde phase de l'enquète policière
commence le juge lui se repose dans une
clinique de la banlieue lyonnaise sans
pour autant se laisser gagner par la
psychose de l'enlèvement il apparaît
nécessaire de faire également ce soir le
point sur le rapt du baron empain nous
en sommes au 18e jour la discrétion
demandée par la famille a été plus ou
moins respecté
on a fait courir les rumeurs les plus
folles sur la rançon et sur l'état de
santé du baron empain
il faut comprendre que dans une telle
affaire le silence est nécessaire bien
sûr mais qu'également il donne lieu à
toutes les élucubrations le groupe
empêche n'aidèrent a dénoncé par exemple
aujourd'hui le caractère irresponsable
de certaines informations qui at il dit
aggrave les périls encourus par l'otage
alors peut-on faire un point sérieux ce
soir robert pietri eh bien nous vous
l'avons déjà dit si même les affaires en
main n'a aucun caractère politique a été
conçue et réalisée par le milieu à
milieu tout particulièrement attentifs à
ce qui se passe dans les cercles de jeu
le baron empain par ailleurs citoyen au
dessus de tout soupçon était connu comme
un gros flambeur un gros joueur il sait
donc désigner lui-même à la tension est
à la convoitise de ses futurs ravisseurs
cela explique que la police criminelle
entendre à ce moment même
systématiquement tous les gens qui
jouent gros tous ceux qui ont approché
le richissime industriel car la police
n'a rien relâcher de son étreinte elle
ne veut en aucun cas que les ravisseurs
puisse fuir impunément
une autre difficulté explique que les
négociations durent car il y as
négociations permanentes entre
l'entourage du baron les gangsters
malgré le barrage de la police et malgré
le silence officiel
cet autre difficulté c'est le montant de
la rançon
ils voulaient 10 milliards au début puis
8 on en serait actuellement à 3 ce qui
est déjà colossale cette rançon serait
versée pour une part en francs et pour
une autre part en monnaie étrangère pour
une part en france et pour l'autre par
dans les villes étrangères
tout ça est très compliqué à mettre au
point plus les tractations traînent plus
les positions se durcissent et plus la
famille et l'entourage prennent leurs
distances avec la police
la partie se jouait à deux au début elle
se joue désormais à 3 la famille
entourage les truands la police quant au
quatrième partenaire si j'ose dire c'est
le pauvre tache meurtri une première
photo montrer sa main bandée sur le
revers de son veston
une autre photo montre sa main posée à
plat sur une table
elle semble ensanglanté la vie sauve du
baron empain
c'est tout de même cela ne l'oublions
pas l'enjeu de cette partie difficile
oui vraiment c'est ça la page politique
de ce soir pourrait encore commencé par
le franc qui après le redressement de ce
matin accompagné d'un nouveau recul de
l'or a été contestée à nouveau sur
diverses places étrangères
je n'ai pas besoin de vous rappeler que
la chute du franc ces derniers jours a
été l'objet de polémiques politiques le
gouvernement
la mettons au compte des incertitudes
électorales l'opposition estimant que le
gouvernement ne défendez pas
suffisamment lefranc vous avez entendu
là-dessus hier françois mitterrand
le deuxième point important c'est un
article de rené andrieu dans l'humanité
aujourd'hui intitulé le nom de françois
mitterrand c'est un nom à georges
marchais qui proposait de reprendre la
discussion sur le programme commun au
lendemain du premier tour
hier le parti socialiste a dit
clairement qu'on ne pouvait négocier
qu'après le deuxième tour mais il
n'excluait pas une déclaration commune
pour faciliter pour que se fasse les
désistements automatiques entre les deux
tours et bien écrivait rené andrieu
aujourd'hui trop souvent dans le passé
la gauche non communiste a bénéficié des
retraits automatiques communiste et pas
toujours payé de retour et elle en a
profité ensuite pour mener une politique
de droite alors qu'elle avait promis une
politique de gauche
la notion de discipline républicaine à
laquelle le parti socialiste fait
référence est à reléguer au musée de
l'histoire entre le roux et la lampe à
huile et les occasions manquées écrivait
encore rené andrieu à cela françois
mitterrand à nouveau répondu aujourd'hui
sur france inter seule la discipline de
la gauche peut lui permettre de
l'emporter il n'y a pas d'hésitation à
avoir devant l'union
enfin troisième point c'est un nouveau
sursaut d'humeur entre les deux courants
de la majorité après l'intervention de
jacques chirac à antenne 2 hier soir ses
attaques contre jean-jacques
servan-schreiber qui l'a dit être le pas
tron de l'union pour la démocratie
française udf et dont il a souligné
l'antigaullisme notoire n'ont pas été
apprécié du tout ni par l'intéressé ni
par ses partenaires mais commençons ce
journal des législatives avec le premier
ministre raymond barre qui répondait ce
soir en direct aux auditeurs de france
inter il a notamment répondu à une
question sur les sondages qui marquait
ce matin un léger redressement de la
majorité je n'ai jamais pensé que les
jeux étaient faits je suis convaincu
parce que je les dis à diverses reprises
je crois au bon sens et à la sagesse des
français qu'au moment où le choix devra
être fait les français éviteront de
plonger le pays dans la banque ce qui se
passe
selon les sondages que vous dites si tu
es encore que je n'attache pas une
importance exceptionnelle aux sondages
indiquent à mon sens le débit le début
d'une prise de conscience et il me
paraît évident que ce qui se passe dans
l'opposition
d'une part la connaissance meilleur des
conséquences qu'aurait pour la france
l'application du programme commun
l'effet du discours très noble et ready
fait par le président de la république à
verdun sur le doubs
tout cela concourt à faire réfléchir les
français je crois que tous les français
sont entrés dans une période de
réflexion
il est normal qu'il y ait dans la
majorité des familles de pensée diverses
les querelles ne m'intéresse pas
c'est le seul commentaire fait au cours
de cette émission par raymond barre
après certaines déclarations dans la
majorité notamment l'intervention de
jacques chirac hier soir à la télévision
deux points essentiels à retenir de ces
déclarations premièrement si la gauche
l'emporté affirme jacques chirac valéry
giscard d'estaing constatera alors que
le rpr sera le plus solide le plus loyal
et le plus fidèle soutien des
institutions et probablement à ce moment
là le seul
deuxièmement l'udf c'est à dire le gros
regroupement des giscardiens des
centristes et des radicaux
c'est la droite ce regroupement a été
imposé à ses partenaires par jjss un
personnage site avec qui nous gaulliste
n'avons rien de commun
réplique de jean pierre soisson pour le
parti républicain il faut que cessent
ces chamailleries les leaders de la
majorité devraient réserver leur
agressivité pour combattre l'opposition
et ses nouveaux giscardien qui
assureront l'animation de l'udf la seule
formation qui puisse rallier à la
majorité les voix qui lui font encore
défaut
l'egypte est présente quarante candidats
qui feront campagne contre le retour au
régime des partis selon les jeunes
gaullistes quel que soit le résultat des
élections
il faudrait former un gouvernement
d'union nationale un commentaire de
claude estier dans l'hebdomadaire
socialiste l'unité sur le tour de france
électorale du premier ministre
les choses sérieuses pour raymond barre
c'est d'une part la tacc permanente
mensongères et haineuse contre son
principal adversaire françois mitterrand
et le ps et d'autre part l'organisation
d'un climat de peur
destiné à tenter de détourner de la
gauche les électeurs les plus hésitants
jean charbonnel le sort de la majorité
sortante semble désormais scellé
gaulliste d'opposition nous nous
réjouissons de cet échec non par
vengeance mais parce qu'il nous paraît
la préface indispensable au renouveau de
la france enfin nous voudrions vous
présenter deux brochures qui vous
aideront peut-être à vous y retrouver
dans le mécanisme des élections tout
d'abord chez fleurus des députés un
matériel audiovisuel diapositives et
cassettes pour expliquer aux jeunes et
aux autres le métier de député comment
s'élabore une loi les conditions
d'éligibilité et cetera chez hachette
les élections en france préparé par
alain et marie thérèse lancelot les
différentes sortes d'élections comment
on passe des voix en sièges le contrôle
des fraudes ou encore les grands partis
politiques très utile je vous rappelle
qu'après ce journal vous pourrez
assister à l'interview du président de
la république par cinq confrères le
thème la politique étrangère de la
france y compris dans la perspective
électorale je note en passant que le
président continue à jouir d'une
excellente popularité un sondage qui
paraîtra demain à sondage ifop france
soir lui attribue 56% de satisfaits
un point de plus que le précédent
sondage et 38 % de mécontents 1 % de
moins
quant à la cote du premier ministre elle
a baissé d'un point 45 % de satisfaits
il ya toujours davantage de mécontents
102 % de plus que la dernière fois et
puis nous commençons aujourd'hui une
série d' enquête sur les
circonscriptions tests à travers la
france circonscriptions tests cela
signifie que la situation y est
politiquement intéressante pour des
raisons très différentes d'ailleurs par
exemple à cause des primaires serré soit
dans la majorité soit dans la position
soit dans les deux courants en même
temps nous commençons par le xviiie
arrondissement de paris une de décider
circonscription traditionnellement les
plus incertaines de france au plan des
résultats bien sûr on ne sait jamais qui
va gagner ce se joue sur une poignée de
voix bruno masure igal un petit jet
d'eau une station de métro entouré de
bis trouve-t-on maintenant de sex-shops
et oui georges ulmer les temps ont bien
changé et 48 mille électeurs de sa
circonscription peu dans cette foule
cosmopolite dont d'ailleurs beaucoup
n'ont pas le droit de vote
une foule winphone rendu mondialement
célèbre par henry miller et vous en
trouverez beaucoup plus d'électeurs dans
les petites rues calmes et tortueuse
accroché aux flancs de la butte
montmartre chacun vit à l'écart de
l'agitation et cultive le charme discret
de la vie provinciale
plus au nord nouveau changement de décor
un paysage de banlieue avec ses 7000
logements hlm tristement aligner un
quartier populaire qui abrite les plus
grands nombres de quelques 5000 chômeurs
répertoriés et les eaux - le chiffre
annoncé par le candidat communiste dont
c'est ici le bastion j'engage air
dessinateur en bâtiment 46 ans axe sa
campagne sur la misère cachée dans le
18e le pc est passé ici de 25% 67 à
moins de 20% des voix il s'est fait
dépassé de 3 cents voix par le ps en 73
ou pc regrette-t-on maintenant le cadeau
fait en 67 en se désistant perdait pied
qui comptait pourtant mille voix de
retard sur le candidat communiste
le candidat de françois mitterrand 52
ans journaliste en tout cas a su saisir
sa chance et lui en 67 battu en 68
claude estier d'entrées depuis au
conseil municipal de paris battue en 73
par roger chinaud le fidèle lieutenant
de françois mitterrand engage un nouveau
duel avec le fidèle lieutenant de
giscard roger chinaud 44 ans a réussi à
s'implanter dans une circonscription
traditionnellement gaulliste défendu
successivement par louis wallon
alexandre sanguinetti et yves le tac au
municipal claude estier a battu de
justesse roger chinaud colistiers et
malheureux de michel d'ornano
inutile d'insister sur le caractère
éminemment politique de cette belle
entre le porte parole du ps et le
président du groupe giscardien à
l'assemblée une belle qui sera arbitré
par de très nombreux autres candidats à
ce jour un cadre pour le ps d un chômeur
pour le front aux gestionnaires un
ingénieur pour le front national
et puis aussi un jeune avocat pour
écologie 78 des écologistes qui font une
campagne détendu sur des peines au
sérieux avec l'appui d'une radio locale
ont obtenu 10% des voix aux municipales
ou au deuxième tour ils ont fait la
décision en faveur de poser en 67 la
gauche unie avait gagné 260 voix et
perdu en 73 de moins de 600 voix la
gauche a d'ailleurs porté plainte contre
l'inscription de 500 français du gabon
jugement le 14 février dans cette
circonscription c'est vrai chaque voix
comptera c'est pourquoi les résultats de
cette circonscription seront sans doute
un très bon test au premier tour de la
réussite ou non
du pari communiste de rééquilibrage à
gauche et au second tour du bon report
ou non des voix à gauche
bon encore des accrochages aujourd'hui
entre les phalanges libanaises et les
troupes syriennes des accrochages très
vifs notamment un carrefour stratégique
de la banlieue sud-est où l'artillerie
lourde wii a été utilisé beyrouth a
retrouvé l'atmosphère de la guerre ses
habitants avaient pu croire qu'il ne
connaîtrait plus les descentes aux abris
les magasins des écoles fermées les rues
désertes les tirs aveugles de roquettes
depuis deux jours ils redoutent un
nouvel embrasement notre correspondant
permanent 10 heures tout l'est s'est
trouvé là au moment d'un attentat en
pleine ville et vous allez le voir la
réaction d'un témoin et poignante
c'est le ras-le-bol du libanais moyens
qui ne peut plus reprendre qu'on se tire
doux et pour course tirent dessus à
beyrouth
toute la zone chrétienne est sur le pied
de guerre après l'incident qui
opposaient l'armée syrienne et libanaise
les combattants de tous les agents sorti
leurs armes les forces arabes de
dissuasion en cercle les quartiers armes
et les responsables des deux camps
tentent de calmer les esprits tout
combat pourrait relancer une guerre très
meurtrière car elle opposerait l'armée
syrienne à des civils libanais la
tension a cependant atteint le maximum
quand un obus a frappé de plein fouet un
immeuble situé dans un quartier chrétien
au sixième étage chez un artisan
tailleur
un ouvrier a eu le pied arraché nous
étions une cinquantaine de mètres de
l'immeuble
le patron encore sous le choc nous
racontes là sinon moi j'ai déjà dormait
dans la chambre à côté
et soudain j'ai entendu sur l'éclat ici
ai-je entendu le plus de mon ouvrier en
attend france est maintenant à l'hôpital
et pourquoi pas aux enseignants il faut
demander à ces masses est codé des gens
qui sont en ailes de briser la
population ici nous nous employons nous
ont semblé chalon pouillard et où les
métis il en est à présent
cette rencontre a failli ce que je peux
dire ces mots le président sadate
continue son voyage dans les pays
occidentaux
après washington et londres il est
aujourd'hui en allemagne il sera en
france dimanche et lundi avant d'aller à
rome dans toutes ces capitales le
président égyptien plaide pour sa
politique celle de la paix mais sûrement
pas n'importe quel prix anouar el sadate
a connu il faut bien le dire des
déceptions lors de son voyage aux
etats-unis mais aussi des succès non
négligeable
régis faucon le bilan je ferai un
scandale du diable si je n'obtiens pas
satisfaction voilà ce qu'avait confié le
président sadate au journaliste
américain au début de sa visite il n'a
pas fait de scandale et l'on peut donc
imaginer qu'il n'est pas trop déçu même
s'il n'a pas de quoi pavoiser
les optimistes parleront de demi succès
les pessimistes de demi échec toujours
est il que le bilan se présente de la
façon suivante le point le plus
important c'est la question de la
reprise de l'assistance militaire à
l'egypte le président sadate a déclenché
une vaste offensive pour tenter
d'obtenir des avions et pas n'importe
lesquels le président égyptien veut des
f-15 et des f 16
or il se trouve que ce dernier est
l'appareil le plus moderne dont
l'aviation américaine dispose
aujourd'hui les forces aériennes
américaine basée en allemagne de l'ouest
par exemple commence seulement
maintenant à en être dotées pourquoi
anouar el-sadate se montre-t-il c'est
exigeant on pense qu'il veut faire
monter les enchères se mettre en
position de force pour négocier
même s'il doit finalement se contenter
d'appareils plus anciens comme le f 5 e
et de fait le gouvernement américain
pourrait donner le feu vert pour la
vente de 50 de ces appareils autre point
la question des implantations
israéliennes dans les territoires
occupés là le numéro un égyptien a
obtenu partiellement satisfaction
puisque le président carter a réaffirmé
non seulement qu'il désapprouvait ses
implantations selon lui illégale mais
qu'il s'agissait d'un obstacle à la paix
alors el sadate peut en tout cas se
vanter d'avoir réussi ce que l'on
pourrait appeler son opération charme
tout le monde s'accorde à penser aux
états unis qu'il a bien plaidé le
dossier de son pays
pourtant l'avenir seul dira s'il a
vraiment convaincu avec vous jean claude
ainsi les autres nouvelles importantes
de ce journal d'abord le report de
l'exécution de christian masset au 20
février prochain c'est un communiqué de
marama à dramane signé le commandant des
forces armées occidentales du frolinat
qui a annoncé la nouvelle
elle redonne un peu d'espoir à la
famille du jeune français détenus au
tchad
de son côté le comité international de
la croix rouge a demandé la libération
et sans condition des deux otages
français et suisses rappelant que les
conventions de genève interdisent
formellement les prises d'otages à addis
abeba voici une des 300 manifestations
de ces dernières semaines celle ci a eu
pour cadre le square de la cathédrale
si manifestation de soutien au régime se
multiplient à la veille de la contre
offensive et yeux plein dans le désert
de l'ogaden addis abeba s'apprêtera à
lancer des dizaines de milliers d'hommes
dans la bataille pour tenter de
reprendre ce territoire à la semelle
conflit frontalier vietnam aux
cambodgiens tandis que des combats se
poursuivent en territoire cambodgien
sur le plan diplomatique le cambodge
rejette le plan vietnamiens en trois
points cessez le feu pour parler et
traité pour un règlement du conflit
les cambodgiens estime que ce plan est
fait pour tromper simplement le pignon
internationale herbert kappler l'ancien
colonel ss vient de mourir en allemagne
six mois après son évasion d'une prison
d'une prison romaine
en 1944 il fut responsable du massacre
de plusieurs centaines de juifs en
italie dans les tristement célèbres
fausse adrea tine près de rome l'évasion
de cap l'air d'un hôpital romain avait
été organisée par sa propre femme
après 34 ans de détention en france
hausse de 3% du prix des voitures
françaises et cela à compter de lundi
prochain
grève à la sécurité sociale et aux
allocations familiales les 15 16 et 17
février à l'appel des syndicats cgt cfdt
force ouvrière et cftc
ce mouvement est destiné à protester
contre l'échec des discussions
salariales de nombreux clichés seront
donc fermées pendant les trois jours je
voulais rappel le 15 le 16 et le 17
février
c'est sans doute la société matra qui va
qu'on
le satellite français d'observation de
la terre dont le développement pourrait
avoir des prolongements militaire le
gouvernement a décidé aujourd'hui de
consacrer la somme de 700 millions de
francs à ce projet un nouveau diesel
chez citroën il s'agit d'un moteur de 2
litres singles cylindrée développant à
75 chevaux
il est monté désormais sur les c s
palace et sur les breaks de record pour
ce moteur d'après jean-louis burgat son
silence et sa consommation 6 litre et
demi de gasoil à 90 km/heure
l'étrangleur de los angeles est il bien
sous les verrous un acteur de télévision
est entendu par les policiers il a avoué
avoir tué 13 femmes mais il n'est pas
certain que ce soit lui certains pensent
d'ailleurs qu'il s'agit d'un mythomane
qui se fait de la publicité d'un mauvais
goût l'homme a signé une lettre de
confessions et les policiers pensent
tout de même qui va apparaître qu'il
aurait tué au moins une personne
il ya pour ainsi dire plus d'espoir pour
les trois ouvriers ensevelis dans
l'éboulement d'un chantier du xviie
arrondissement
les pompiers tentent actuellement de
dégager les corps mais l'opération est
extrêmement difficile en raison de la
fri habilités des murs de la tranchée
une équipe de télé de tf1 et sur place
d'ailleurs poursuivre les opérations
on aura sans doute des nouvelles dans
notre dernier journal sport après le
match nul de france italie d'hier
confiance et sérénité au sein de
l'équipe de france pour mieux connaître
cette équipe est bien un document
intéressant allez la france il est dû à
la plume de notre ami michel denisot qui
a consacré ce livre tricolore allait la
france aux éditions alain mathieu en ski
les françaises ont confirmé leur bonne
forme d'hier à saint gervais aujourd'hui
à megève elles se sont placées aux
places d'honneur mais c'est la suisse
est ce que vous voyez ici la suissesse
lise-marie more heroes qui a remporté le
slalom géant
la grande perdante de la journée a été
la championne du monde maria et play
éliminé dans la première manche
en deuxième place on retrouve anne marie
paule troisième fabienne serra quatrième
perrine pelen hanni wenzel elle conserve
la première place de la coupe du monde
enfin les résultats du tiercé le 8 le 6
et le 7
voilà il rapporte dans l'ordre vous le
voyez pas sur votre écran 229 francs
pour 5 francs et dans un ordre différent
40 580 le 8 le 6 et le 7
voilà nous sommes en retard je vous dit
bonsoir à tous au nom de toute l'équipe
de tf1 actualité pour le temps sachez qu
il fera froid demain qui aura des chutes
de neige un peu partout bonne soirée à
tous merci